I used to have this mean critical voice
in my head
but I committed to my recovery and I got
better
stop but sometimes I wonder if that
voice is what got me here
are you ready
hi I'm Sheila D Rubin let's move
our national television personality now
we're building a place for women to be
free of judgment
we should offer meditation yoga Pottery
lesbians yes
we're brainstorming there's no bad ideas
yes
we are on the precipice of something big
there's just one problem
[Music]
Kelly kilmartin she beat you to the
punch she's the most famous Fitness star
I'm better than you
[Music]
oh no they're looking at you she's in my
head
scrutiny she's big and a liar every time
I think you have hit bottom you manage
to sink even lower this is really
starting to scare me you don't want to
slow down now do you get so close to the
top I was hoping it wouldn't come to
this just kidding I was dying for it to
come to this it's got time
this is more than just a business for me
this is my life I built this I am Body
by Sheila
[Music]
you're just hanging on by a thread just
waiting for that moment to snap I
thought you were on a healing Journey
we have put everything on the line what
if it doesn't work
I won't let that happen
[Music]
isn't one of the steps in your recovery
Integrity recovery's a long road
[Music]